ah animated holiday specials make me
feel like I was bitten by a radioactive
humbug I explain why on this week's
episode of angry nerd a year ago I
gushed about how Shane Black's profane
Christmastime action movies always made
my Yuletide totally awesome many thanks
to Sparta kerkhoff and Jackson area and
everyone else who commented on that
video but this year the endless parade
of sickly sweet holiday cartoons that
started airing around the clock the day
after Thanksgiving has preempted my
regularly scheduled good move I feel
like I'm living in a Hallmark card worst
of all I just learned the toy story that
time for God a reunion special featuring
all of the original cast which I've been
so looking forward to is going to be
holiday-themed Pixar what have you
wrought humbug I say holiday specials
can kiss my rank and bass do my eyes
deceive me a visitation from an
otherworldly spirit who sounds just like
TVs Chris Hardwick actually he was on
oovoo what i was told that we were going
to get Chris Hardwick to guest re
beggars can't be choosers tubby I
usually hear that my voice resembles how
ludlim you know from the thrilling
adventure hour yeah yeah awesome
Hardwick is dead to me enough about that
an insufferable grump you have been
proved to you the error of your ways I
shall wait wait are you a spirit are you
yoda I am the ghost of Christmas
specials asked here to show you that
holiday themed cartoons can be totally
awesome and geek friend really what is
the least convincing spectral presence
this side of ghost dad possibly have to
teach me about television let me take
you back
in time to 1985 wait he said is that the
he-man and Shera Christmas special I
found its message inspiring as a child
and I searched in vain for a he-man in a
Santa costume toy curse you Mattel Thank
You mr. Skeletor you are very kind if
even Skeletor can learn to love the
holidays then maybe I no no your
nostalgia powers will not work on me
spirit don't even bother trying to show
me GI joe cobra claws are coming to town
ok then what about these the tick
Christmas episode with an army of folk
Kris kringles oh man I wore out my VHS
copy of this is this putting you in the
holiday spirit no no I stand by my
humbug that ticks special aired a long
time ago no new cartoons can live up to
that really what about these cartoons
taught me that whether we get our
presence from Hanukkah zombie or Kwanzaa
bot we must never forget the reason for
the season protecting yourself from evil
robot santa all this a very venture
Christmas with Santa's demon friend
Krampus you see now nerd even this toy
story that time forgot special will
touch you check out the warlike
battlesaurs which are a parody of the
action figures that you youthful own
when you knew love spirit my heart is
grown three sizes I want to share the
good cheer of the season with the
characters I've come to love that's why
these special episodes work overtime we
come to think of these familiar
characters as a sort of a family the
holidays are a time to reflect on our
lives with the venture brothers with
fatigue or with the Toy Story gang
because the stories while silly actually
do give our lives a kind of meaning and
the reminder of values that only
superheroes science fiction and stop
motion reindeer can convey so you're
saying people should spend the holidays
with their fictional TV families
no that's not what I that's a really
good point you still hate enough I got
it I got it go bust yourself ghost I
have some TV to watch and to you my
loyal nerdlings I say Happy Holidays
even you Michael babe what are your most
favorite and least favorite holiday
specials let me know in the comments and
subscribe to the wire channel oh and
here's a philosophical dilemma for you
is nightmare before christmas a
halloween special or is it a Christmas
special see I go back and forth on the
bulk of the film takes place after
Halloween in the run-up to Christmas but
it's so goth looking dark hey let me
know what you think in the comments